[музыка]
убирают 6 номер
поэтому шестой номер жеребьевки убирает
это может быть причина что вас никто не
слышит канал может забыться
[музыка]
сразу блокируется
запомнил сразу прием прием слышу слышу
вас цифровизация
[музыка]
[аплодисменты]
Так что я ни разу не путешествовал по
Казахстану
с точки зрения именно путешествия То
есть я просто был в городах там с
гастролями с концертами когда маргулан
позвал я немного был даже немного
скептически настроен с точки зрения
организации так далее но в этом плане
было здесь все тут все профессионально
Все круто Все Рассчитано и здорово
что касается
природы пейзажи Я вообще у меня реально
нет слов То есть у меня и так скудные
словарный запас когда я вижу что-то
просто величественное это просто
остается смотреть это наблюдать
Созерцать и молчать Поэтому меня я не
могу сформулировать свои ощущения когда
каждый раз каждая локация то есть на
протяжении всего дня одни красоты Я
просто в восторге поэтому класс
[музыка]
а меня зовут Сергей меня и ернур зовут
Арман маралов Я из города нур-султан
Меня зовут Алихан я из города Алматы
Меня зовут кураков шутимур Привет Меня
зовут Николай тесенко и что я от этого
получаю масса впечатлений от этой
поездки я увидел то чего не видел ни в
одной стране мира сейчас будем есть плов
и шашлык говорят И кстати кухня просто
на высшем уровне я думаю будет армейская
лагерная нет
супер вкусно свежо Здорово жирно сплю
потом как младенец
[музыка]
вот такие вот поездки Это в жизни думаю
надо как это щелчок перезагрузка почему
потому что это очень эффективно Но это
перезагрузка полная мы посетили
невероятные места и впечатление просто
море ежедневно меняющиеся горизонты Я
безумно потрясен покорен природой
эмоциями людьми такая красота она просто
поражает наверное воображение Зачем
куда-то ехать целенаправленно какие-то
планы стоят когда у нас в Казахстане
такие места
[музыка]
Я никогда так не отдыхал стандартами мой
отдых это
пятизвездочная аталия тюленчиком пять
дней пролежаться возле бассейна Вот это
стандартный мой отдых всегда так
самый жизни было тогда когда я
подписался на эту поездку сначала
очень кайфово Я сегодня чуть не
перевернул не перевернул баги
чудом благодаря тому что я смотрел фильм
Форсаж 2000 каком-то году я вспомнил что
надо выкручивать руль в сторону когда
переворот идет куда переворачивается
Просто я люблю экстремальные
[музыка]
с днём рождения
[аплодисменты]
тридцатник пошёл
переосмысление или перезагрузка я думаю
это будет
ясно
после поездки То есть я сейчас просто
наслаждаюсь
каждой минутой иногда бывает моменты я
просто себя как пацан чувствую как
какой-то подросток то есть мы тут на
баги ездим по лужам очень круто все
мокрые грязные как собаки поэтому я
просто кайфую и я думаю это есть
перезагрузка по большому счету нету
лишних мыслей мыслей о работе и так
далее Поэтому просто чисто кайф
водохранилище такое место очень Дикое
просто единица самим собой прям круто
посидеть посмотреть полежать подышать Ну
и в горах горы все эти перевалы ущелья
тоже придают сил поэтому
все места крутые не было еще места где я
был бы
недоволен или что это красиво и это при
том что мы еще не все объездили
То есть тут огромное количество мест Я в
шоке что я знал что Казахстан очень
красив но когда я лично это увидел это
просто взрыв
Всем рекомендую
[музыка]
[аплодисменты]